c'est ce d'effry buteur qui a mis la
puce à l'oreille des autorités alors
qu'il perd sony effectuer un retrait
d'argent
le dispositif vidéo tomb devant elle
elle prévient les gendarmes les
militaires se saisissent de l'enquète et
identifie grâce aux caméras de
surveillance cet homme c'est lui qui
aurait trafiqué le distributeur la photo
est issue de documents internes à la
gendarmerie qui n'aurait pas dû fuiter
mme azila largement diffusés sur les
réseaux sociaux les commerçants du coin
eux sont en courant depuis plusieurs
jours l'un d'eux aurait même identifié
l'individu aperçu plusieurs fois en
compagnie d'un autre homme est venu
plusieurs fois chine aimerait en la
serbie et en ligne deux jours d'affilée
voilà et c'est après que j'ai su que
c'était un voleur belge des services et
des gars super bien habillé a très bien
anglais on les aurait pris pour des
touristes dans la sphère révélé le 20
mai dernier pourrait déjà avoir mené à
des arrestations
la gendarmerie n'a pour l'instant pas
souhaité communiquer